hey guys welcome back to the channel
admittedly I've got a pretty low effort
video for you guys this week because I
felt really shitty this entire time had
a bad headache uh and then I proceeded
to spend as little time as possible on
my YouTube channel uh slightly different
Channel announcement coming up which is
that I will begin to be doing some
sponsored posts starting in May now you
may be thinking to yourself oh Jordan uh
well evidently you must need this money
for production costs on the channel
right and to keep things going like
every other YouTuber says uh no I don't
I'm just greedy it cost me0 to make
these videos I'm incredibly lazy it's
just me writing on my iPad uh but I
would just like a few hundred extra
dollars so uh if you are complaining
about the advertisements that would be
why I guess you're welcome to skip them
um but otherwise I'm going to try and
make them uh the least bit painful as
possible and hopefully a little bit
funny so let's go ahead and get into
some systems design and then we can all
have ourselves a great weekend okay so
today we're going to be talking about
how to build a notification service so
I'm just letting you guys know right off
the bat this is going to be a relatively
short video the reason being that
building a notification service is a
pattern that we've now seen three
different times on this channel and that
pattern is going to be what I like to
dub the fan out pattern AK when you
deliver a message to a variety of users
that are all subscribed or interested to
some sort of topic we've seen this in
Dropbox when we have to send document
changes to a variety of interesting
users we've seen it with Facebook
Messenger when we we basically have to
do the same and we've seen it with
Twitter and so really what I want to do
in this video is formalize that pattern
once and for all and then maybe add a
little bit of extra thought into how we
can make sure that we've delivered each
message only once to every single client
and then from there we'll call it a day
so everyone can have a nice Saturday so
what does a notification service look
like well obviously if I'm on my phone
here we've got a few different types of
messages that I can receive from a bunch
of different applications but even
though these are from different
applications they're effectively
centralized through the actual device
provider themselves like like apple for
example has a push notification server
that when you're making an app you would
hook into and you would hit some API to
actually push a notification there cool
so let's formalize some problem
requirements and capacity estimates
again this is a pretty abstract problem
so I'm going to you know just try and
give some very broad capacity estimates
then maybe we'll discuss them a little
bit more concretely later in the video
so the idea is that if we have a bunch
of users let's say on our cell phone
device we want to be able to give them
notific ifications in real time based on
some sort of topic now in theory it is
possible that notifications might be
sent to a specific device ID but at
least in my opinion I guess that's a
little bit of an easier problem you just
go send it to their specific device ID
and uh yeah or maybe to the server that
they're connected to if they're
connected via some sort of websocket or
something like that and then number two
is that if users are offline we need to
be able to store their notifications so
that we can run some sort of query and
ultimately fetch them later cool so
another thing is if we have let's say a
billion topics because at the end of the
day there are a lot of apps out there
they're probably each registering their
own topic and each user or uh basically
each topic is going to receive a th000
notifications per day of around 100
bytes on average now all of a sudden if
we have to store all of these messages
in our database we're storing 100
terabytes of data per day 30 pedabytes a
year so that's a lot it means we're
going to definitely have to be doing
some amount of partitioning in our
tables and uh whenever we're doing
partitioning and we have data
distributed across multiple nodes it
does allow us to do a little bit of
caching to speed up reads at times cool
so again note the topics can have
millions of users subscrib to them in
the same way that if I'm running Twitter
a given person who's posting tweets can
have millions of followers or if I'm
running Dropbox a given document can
have millions of users subscribe to
those changes so the question is do we
always want to push the notification to
each user well if you're thinking of
those previous videos and thinking about
the patterns here the answer is probably
not cool so the first thing that I'm
going to do is try and formalize that
fan out design path patter because at
least on my channel it's probably always
going to look the same there are many
different ways of implementing this type
of thing but you know how I do it which
is that I am going to go jerk off over
flank and uh we're going to do things
that way so if we have all of these
notifications to be delivered we would
just be throwing them into a Kafka
stream and we can Shard that up by the
actual topic ID uh we would also have to
have um in our Flint consumer uh we need
to have a sense of basically which users
care about which topics right so that we
can say something like oh for the
messages topic user 10 and 12 are
subscribed to that well the way that we
would do this is you know as opposed to
having to have flank reach out to the
database every single time of topic
subscriptions to figure out all the
users that care about a topic that takes
a lot of time those are expensive reads
there are potentially a lot of users
that are subscribed to a given topic
what would be better is if we could
actually just pre-populate our flank
node with all of this information per
topic ID that our flank node cares about
so instead what we'll do is we'll take
our topic subscription table we can
Shard It Out by user ID the reason being
that in the future we'll want to figure
out for a given user what topics they
care about but then when we actually
push this change data to Kafka we can
basically rehart it by our topic ID and
so this goes in sharted by topic ID so
that Flink can easily consume to just
one kofka Q or listen to One kofka q and
that way for every single topic that
Flink cares about it knows what users
subscribe to it so the thing to note
here is that for certain topics uh we're
going to have way too many users
subscribing to it right such that it
doesn't actually make sense to deliver
that message to each user individually
the cost is just going to be too
expensive so maybe we've got some other
topic called
all and Flink realizes oh shoot you know
what I've got a th users subscrib to
this thing we're just going to write
down here we're not going to store all
that state we're just going to call it
popular cool so let's say we do that
basically depending on whether this
incoming message is for the messages
topic let's say that's going to user 10
and 12 so then you know flank also can
either have some intermediary layer to
reach out to or just read from zookeeper
but the point is now it knows where to
Route these messages to eventually get
them to user 10 and 12 they have to go
to our sync servers so maybe this is the
server that's connected to user 10 this
is the server that's connected to user
12 so it's going to send that message
both here and over here on the other
hand if a message all comes
in now that's a popular one I want to
send it to the popular messages server
which is going to treat this thing a
little bit differently
AKA it's not going to try and send them
to individual users uh we're just going
to end up polling that later but I'll
discuss that in a little bit cool so the
main uh kind of nuance of this video
that I want to discuss that I probably
didn't spend too much time discussing in
the Facebook Messenger or the Google
Drive video is uh item potent so we do
want to make sure that all of our
messages are delivered only once so the
nice thing about flank is that flank is
going to ensure that all of those
messages are going to be delivered at
least once right because of the way that
Flink does checkpointing so at least
within Flink we know that all of these
messages are going to be handled at
least once over here and then depending
on how we handle kind of Downstream all
of the messages that get to our sync
servers we know that uh they're going to
be delivered to the user at least once
so it's our job to make sure that
they're going to be delivered only once
and not more than once or at least
processed only once so what could we
actually do well keep in mind that our
notification server right that's just
forwarding messages to the user so
that's state list if it hears from flank
it's just going to say ooh am I
connected to this user let me go ahead
and forward this over there so again
this message is going to deliver at
least once due to that flank uh kind of
state replay so the question is well
what can we do to actually ensure that
our client isn't just showing duplicate
notifications all the time one thing we
could do is that we can actually store
the notifications that we've seen or at
least the IDS of them on the client to
make sure that we don't redeliver them
so the concept of this is called
something like an item potency key
meaning that uh you know we're basically
just keeping a little bit of memory on
our client uh and you know keeping a set
and making sure that you know based on
hashing that IDE that we don't already
have it somewhere on our client the
problem is this is going to use up extra
memory the question is how much extra
memory and do we actually
care so uh in theory um basically if we
are going to assume that uh you know
we're getting about a th000
notifications per day on a device and
each one is 16 bytes because that's how
much a uu ID which we could use for our
ID and potency key takes that alone is
going to be like basically 16 kilobytes
which is not so bad and in theory we
could totally store this on the client
but uh I would imagine that in a systems
design interview someone might push you
a little bit and say well what if we
don't want to use that extra memory
footprint on the client let's go ahead
and try and store all of these item
potency Keys elsewhere to which I say
fair enough um you know I suppose in
certain edge cases this would be too
much memory for certain devices maybe
you've got like like an apple watch or
something and uh at the end of the day
that is just not going to have the
memory to store all of this so again uh
if we wanted to store this let's say on
our actual notification server itself so
that would be up here the thing
forwarding the messages that means we
would have to store all of the item
potent keys for all of the users that
that notification server is uh cares
about and so let's say it's connected to
around 65,000 users CU that's around how
many ports you can use to connect to
people that comes out to around a
gigabyte of memory which itself is not
too bad but again they may push you and
say well what if it were greater than
this what would you do then so the one
thing I want to note about actually
keeping all of these uh keys on our
server to ensure that we aren't sending
duplicate messages to the client is that
we have the potential for partial
failures right so let's say that uh one
thing that we do is we say okay we're
going to send our message to the client
and then when we hear back from the
client saying I got the message we're
going to keep track of that item potency
key so we don't actually send that
message again well what about when the
client device for whatever reason is
sending that uh acknowledgement back to
the notification server and it doesn't
work well we're never actually going to
add the ad in potency key so that's one
partial failure scenario and the other
is that you might say oh well what if
instead of uh keeping track of the item
potency key after we send it to the
client we write it down before we send
it to the client uh and then we'll just
go ahead and store that around well it
would be possible that you know we write
down the item potency key so it's like
key1 we try and send that over to the
client that doesn't work out for us and
then maybe our server goes down so it
never actually realizes that the client
didn't get it now all of a sudden we've
added an Iden potency key for an
undelivered message which is bad because
if that message then comes in again and
we want to redeliver it we're not going
to do so and that's never going to get
to the client so in theory if we did
want to make this process completely
perfect we would need two-phase commit
in practice uh it's not really the end
of the world if you don't get a push
notification received and so who cares
uh but yeah you know note that uh if we
want everything to be proper we would
have to basically add our item potency
key conditional on the fact that the
client device is able to process it and
that of course is a distributed
transaction which requires two phase
commit cool so the last piece of this is
you know maybe you say o you know 16 or
a gigabyte of memory on our notification
server we just don't want to pay for
that we would rather do this all on disk
in some sort of database so you know
let's imagine instead we got 10,000
messages a day per user and all of a
sudden we need to store 16 gbt of memory
and that's just too much for our
notification server we could actually do
this in a database like I
mentioned and uh the way we would do
that to probably make reads and writes
as fast as possible is we would go ahead
and index on our specific item potency
key and then partition the table by user
ID so that you know for a given user and
a given item potency key we can at least
relatively quickly jump into that index
and find it however uh this is obviously
going to incur quite a bit of extra
latency as in step one we have to check
whether the item potency key exists step
two we have to go ahead and write our
message to the client and then in step
three we have to write that item potency
key back to the database so is there
anything that we can do to optimize this
process a little bit well actually in
fact there is we could use something
like a bloom filter so a bloom filter is
going to allow us to ideally get rid of
this step one where we have to read the
database to check if uh that item
potency key has been seen already it's
not perfect but at least some percentage
of the time the bloom filter will help
us out here so a bloom filter is a
probabilistic data structure that we've
spoken about plenty of times on this
channel but I'll quickly go over it one
more time so the idea is that we
basically want to avoid one extra read
to database so let's say I see some key
called Jordan right that's going to hash
and basically our Bloom filter is a fix
size memory buffer that uh involves
basically using multiple hash functions
to map a given key to multiple places in
the memory buffer so let's say hash
function one is going going to map the
key Jordan over here into that bucket
hash function two maps it into this
bucket hash function three Maps it into
this bucket then we add the key Kate uh
Kate is going to go here here and here
with our three hash functions and then
the key Megan comes around and we want
to say o have we already seen Megan well
we know already just using hash function
one that we haven't because there's no
other element that's already filled up
this bucket right here so Megan has to
be unique even if this guy went and
hashed over here and this guy on hash
two hashed over here we could see that
because hash function 3 put Megan in a
unique bucket that Megan is a key that
we have not already seen and then we
don't actually have to read the database
we can just go ahead and send that
message right over to the client without
incurring an extra read cost now it is
the case that you know we might see a
key and it looks like it is completely
in the bloom filter but we can't
guarantee that it is because those
buckets may have been filled up by a
combination of other keys so the bloom
filter will tell us when we haven't
already seen a key but we can't be sure
that we have already seen a key so
that's worth noting so of course when we
haven't already seen that message we
don't have to read the database we just
go ahead and write it right to our
client so you can see that I'm uh losing
my voice a little bit here but I'm going
to try and get through the rest of this
thing so as far as the client is
concerned right because the client
itself is connected to the notification
service we need to be able to do two
things the first is that for the
messages that don't have to be delivered
to too many users which I'll call the
unpopular ones we want to be delivered
bring those in real time so the idea
here is that again we've got some sort
of routing server right and we've used
this pattern as well in a ton of places
Uber Facebook Messenger all that so the
routing server is basically just going
to look at the existing notification
servers how many connections they have
probably use some sort of consistent
hashing schema on the user ID and then
assign a notification server to a given
user that wants to connect to one so
it's going to assign it some sort of
address based on consistent hashing and
then if for whatever reason uh you know
they're sending heartbeats back and
forth with one another and uh the client
server real or the client device
realizes that it's no longer connected
to that notification Service uh it will
just reach right back out to the routing
server to get another connection now the
one thing I wanted to point out is we
should probably do a random Jitter uh
every time that that connection breaks
down to basically wait a little bit
before we reconnect otherwise if one
notification server goes down we're
going to have all of its multiple
thousands of devices trying to reconnect
to new servers at the same time and that
could cause a Thundering Herd cool the
next thing is that we also want to be
polling popular messages on an interval
so the idea here is that you know
because uh we have all this information
stored in our database and partitioned
by user we can really quickly just get
all of our topic subscriptions for a
given client device and then that is
going to tell me whether a given topic
is also popular right so one thing that
I didn't mention too much is that in
this fan out pattern when Flink deems
that a given uh topic is popular because
it's subscribed to all of its users it
can actually go ahead and reach back out
to the Topic's table and say hey by the
way this topic is now considered a
popular one or we could make it user
configurable as well like an app might
be able to say hey I'm going to send
this particular notification to all
users Market in advance as a popular
topic either way works um but you know
it's a design
specific cool so the idea is um you know
when we figure out which information on
a given po uh topic is popular then we
can basically go ahead and go to our
actual notifications table which uh you
know something like Cassandra works
because we want fast ingestion there
through the lstm tree or rather the LSM
tree which is uh buffered in memory and
basically also multiple different leader
nodes and then we can just read from
Cassandra we can partition It Out by
topic so that uh we can easily find
those messages and sort within a topic
on timestamp which is going to make our
life pretty
easy cool sorry I'm brushing through
this one guys I just am in quite a bit
of pain at the moment so let me go ahead
and finish it off so as you can see as
far as the actual notification service
diagram goes uh it's pretty standard to
what we describing in this full video on
the left let's actually first discuss
how a client is going to receive
notifications basically we've got you
know our client over here and on one
side we've got some sort of notification
server router which is going to listen
to zookeeper get the current consistent
hashing policy connect us to a
notification server and then once we're
connected to a notification server we
can communicate back and forth sending
one another heartbeats via websockets
this is going to allow me as the client
to realize if I'm still connected to the
notification server and if I'm not then
I have to once again go back here and
reconnect to a different one cool so
that is going to make sure that I'm
getting basically the unpopular
notifications for the popular
notifications I'm going to go ahead and
read from my load balancer I'm going to
hit my notification polling service
which is now going to all of a sudden
basically tell me what topics I'm
subscribed to and then from knowing the
topics that I'm subscribed to I can
actually go ahead and first off read
from some sort of popular notifications
cache which is in redus uh this guy is
just going to basically act as a proxy
between the actual notifications
database table and uh hopefully should
end up being filled with all of the
popular notifications because those are
going to be getting read a lot more uh
we can just use an lru replacement
policy to basically ensure this and then
that is going to be getting uh proxied
information from our actual
notifications table that I just
described before so this guy is going to
be Cassandra because we are going to be
publishing a ton of messages there from
flank and uh it would be good to be able
to injust them pretty quickly we can
Shard this guy by our topic ID and sort
it by our timestamp that way we can
basically just say for a given topic
that I want to get the messages for all
of our messages that I care about
between these two time stamps are
already pre-index so it should be a
relatively fast query and ideally most
of the time we're just going to be
hitting over here on our cache as far as
flank is concerned basically the way
that this works like I mentioned before
is using the fan out pattern so we have
all of our topic subscriptions this can
just be stored in a mySQL database we're
not going to be reading there too often
we're not going to be writing there too
often but we are going to be reading
from there a decent amount and as a
result of that I think using SQL or a B
tree based database is going to be nice
here and also again it just keeps things
simple sh this guy out on user ID and
then when we actually put everything in
Kafka apologies typo here on my end this
cka que should be sharded on topic ID at
which point we go ahead ahead and put
everything into Flink so Flink is itself
sharded again on topic ID so that per
topic that it cares about it has a sense
of all the users that it needs to go
ahead and reach out
to so when a message comes in from our
actual notification queue over here and
this can be published from a variety of
different places right every app is
effectively publishing to this massive
CFA Q probably through some sort of you
know notification service that then you
know proxies over to this cofa but the
gist is that flank is basically going to
get the
messages put them in the notifications
table whether they're popular or not and
then also assuming they're not popular
it is going to Fan them out to the
proper notification servers that we care
about and so we can either you know do
that fan out via some sort of middleware
over here that's listening to a
zookeeper or we can have Flink itself
listen to zookeeper you know get a sense
of where the messages actually have to
be delivered and then deliver them uh
deliver them there accordingly
well guys I hope this video was somewhat
helpful again like nothing too novel
here in terms of um what we've actually
spoken about in this series so far the
reason being that I want to just Hammer
home the point that at least for four to
five of these problems that I've covered
right now this fan out problem or rather
this fan out design is going to be
something that you want to really know
super well and uh have that in the back
of your head and also be able to
recognize when to use it uh because it
will definitely come in handy anyways I
hope you all enjoy your weekend and uh I
will see you in the next one